7000 répétitions d'abdominaux en une
heure Christiane Joson place la barre
très haut pour cette tentative de record
du monde un défi personnel un défi pour
les autres un défi pour le Téléthon déjà
au départ quand on fait déjà 5 minutes
on trouve déjà que c'est long c'est long
je me dis 5 minutes mais j'arriverai
jamais à faire une heure
on sent pas que c'est possible et petit
à petit à force de séance on y arrive
c'est du travail un petit peu de longue
haleine mais on y arrive et pour y
arriver il a fallu une année
d'entraînement pour acquérir la
technique l'endurance physique et
mentale Roger Prévot et son préparateur
cet homme de 76 ans est un féru de
musculation 5 fois champion de France de
bodybuilding vainqueur d'une coupe
d'Europe en 1995 et surtout détenteur du
record du monde d'abdominaux en une
heure on est parti à partir de la
première semaine de janvier avec une
minute ensuite deux minutes ensuite mais
toutes les semaines toutes les semaines
toutes les semaines semaines pour
finalement arriver à faire une heure au
mois de juin ou là déjà cette tentative
là c'est soldée par 6900 REP en 2001
Roger Prévot avait battu le record
d'abdo déjà l'occasion du Téléthon 650
de répétitions record pas encore battus
ce soir au sol Michaud de
Montlouis-sur-Loire l'élève christiane
est en voie de dépasser le maître